welcome back did you know that nevada
has bicycle laws eric palacios from eric
palacios and associates the sponsors of
this segment share three rules of the
road to follow while riding a bicycle
[Music]
hi i'm eric palacios welcome to the
legal minute today we're going to answer
the question what three rules of the
road do you need to follow if you're
riding a bicycle
cyclists have to follow the rules just
like cars do here's a top three rules
cyclists must follow
number one they have to obey stop lights
and stop signs you should not blow a
stop sign or a red traffic light
first of all it's dangerous and secondly
you may be sighted
number two cyclists should drive with
traffic not against traffic this means
on the right side of the road many
cyclists feel safer driving against
traffic or on the left side of the road
but this is against the law if you
suffer an accident you will probably be
found to be at fault and number three
don't ride your bicycle on sidewalks
sidewalks are for pedestrians you're
required to ride your bike on the street
if you're in an accident with a car or a
pedestrian you will probably be found at
fault if you were riding on the sidewalk
if you have any questions about a
pedestrian or bicycle accident always
consult with an experienced attorney
this has been the legal minute we'll see
you next time
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call at
their website at 702-444-7777